il y a trois ans nous vous avions
présenté un reportage sur une érablière
tout près de rouyn noranda en abitibi
les chercheurs tentaient de comprendre
comment des érables s'était retrouvé
dans une région aussi nordiques et bien
après plusieurs années de recherche il
croit avoir enfin percer ce mystère
[Musique]
c'est du jamais vu en
abitibi-témiscamingue une érablière
sauvage au 48e degrés de latitude nord à
la frontière de l'ontario et du québec
dans une forêt de sapins et de bouleau
jaune
cette découverte a de quoi surprendre
les scientifiques
d'autant plus que ses érables à sucre
eux se retrouvent bien au delà de leur
aire de répartition
pour connaître l'origine de cette
érablière
il aura fallu carotter le centre du lac
labelle en extraire 7 mètres de
sédiments contenant du pollen des
feuilles des matières végétales et du
charbon vestiges des feux puis nettoyez
les dépôts et comptes et les graines
pollen à 3 nob qui caractérise les
érables à sucre eu en tout trois années
de recherches menées çà sent la glace
les os
olivier pla requête a dirigé ces travaux
la thèse de maîtrise de jardin paillard
comme le montre ce graphique la présence
des premiers pollens d'érable à secrets
remontent à dix mille ans donc le
graphique est assez simple on est ici
dix mille ans avant aujourd'hui et ici
le présent donc là on peut voir tout
d'abord une présence de du du pollen
d'érable à sucre entre 10000 à peu près
et 6500 on sait que durant cette période
là on était plutôt dans une une période
soit de toundra donc plutôt là entre
10000 et 9000 ans et ensuite une période
d'afforestation c'est à dire une période
avec très peu de d'armes
le pollen venaient du sud lac chasseurs
le lac labelle qui si à cette époque et
ils pouvaient être transportées sur plus
de 150 km de distance grâce à de forts
vents où il n'y a pas d'effets filtre de
la végétation et où probablement ya il
ya au niveau de l'atmosphère des plus
grandes capacités de dispersion au
niveau de l'atmosphère c'est à dire des
courants des courants ascendants des
courants
ou des courants horizontaux qui qui
permettent le début le déplacement à
longue distance
puis soudainement autour de 6000 en
avant aujourd'hui on ne retrouve plus
aucunes traces de pollens d'érable à
sucre la forêt s'est densifié bloquant
tout transport de pollen
il faut attendre quelques centaines
d'années avant de voir réapparaître le
pollen de l'érable dans les sédiments au
dessus de cette ligne rouge on considère
que le pollen représente une érablière
qui était à côté du lac
on suppose que déjà depuis quatre mille
cinq cents ans l'érablière qu'on voyait
au lac labelle étaient étaient présentes
quatre mille cinq cents à l'origine de
l'érablière serait donc plus récente que
ce que les scientifiques avaient cru à
cette époque il y avait beaucoup d 110
probablement des incendies de sous bois
les incendier de surface qui n'ont pas
réussi ou qui n'étaient pas suffisamment
sévère pour complètement exclure à
l'érable c'est à dire on pensait que
l'érable aurait pu s'installer au profit
de période sans incendie ou de périodes
plus chaudes c'est pour ça qu'on avait
une date qui était plus ancien à
l'époque me n'en est rien finalement il
s'installe pendant une période via plus
incendie où il fait relativement plus
froid par rapport au climat l'optimum
climatique holocène donc c'est ça un peu
la pelle la part surprenante des
résultats
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'érablière fait à peine 4
hectares elle s'était installée alors
que la température était plus élevé que
maintenant entre 1 et 2 degrés de plus
depuis quelques décennies on constate
une hausse des températures alors
peut-on s'attendre à ce que s'était
rhabillé en nordic prennent de
l'expansion dans le futur avec le
réchauffement climatique
encore faudrait-il que les érables soit
capable de s'installer dans des
peuplements dominé à l'heure actuelle
par les conifères
la réponse c'est l'avenir qui nous le
dira